es viernes por la noche el comienzo del
sábado un momento especial para esta
inusual congregación judía que no es del
todo como las demás
estos fieles le dieron la espalda a sus
comunidades ultraortodoxas hace unos
meses para reconstruir sus vidas aquí en
dresde alemania todos crecieron en estas
comunidades religiosas aisladas del
mundo exterior junto con el rabino aquí
va avant garde en quien creó este centro
de estudios en un antiguo hotel
continúan con la tradición pero con
mucha más libertad que nunca
normalmente es un momento que se pasa en
familia pero aquí estamos sin familia y
es importante pasar este momento juntos
es muy diferente es importante
socialmente
[Música]
este centro fue fundado hace un año en
dresde en alemania oriental es
financiado por donaciones privadas y
único en europa los ultraortodoxos que
abandonaron sus comunidades son a menudo
rechazados aislados y no tienen recursos
aquí viven juntos cocinan juntos y
asisten a cursos diarios de alemán con
el fin de integrarse a la sociedad
alemana un proceso que se complica con
la pandemia
mira
y la gramática no es para nada fácil
es un idioma complicado pero creo que
será mucho más fácil cuando podamos
volver a salir y conocer gente
mientras tanto todos pasan la mayor
parte del tiempo en esta casa cómo se
creció en jerusalén era una de diez
hermanos toda su vida se dedicó al
estudio de la torá y nada más aquí
estaba aprendiendo a vivir una vida más
independiente
cada uno tiene su propia habitación esta
es la mía es mi rincón para trabajar
no se dejó su comunidad ultra-ortodoxa
con el pretexto de realizar estudios
religiosos en dresde una decisión
difícil de aceptar para su familia
mi abuelo se asustó cuando se lo dije
pero la familia está aprendiendo a
aceptarlo dentro ex a tec like sin
embargo a mucha gente todavía le da
miedo alemania light
pero este salto a lo desconocido fue
amortiguado cuando conoció a otros en su
misma situación el centro acoge a 8
personas actualmente pero quiere
aumentar su capacidad de
[Música]
todos venimos de comunidades
ultraortodoxas y nos entendemos es más
fácil mudarse a una nueva ciudad y
aprender con gente que se enfrenta a las
mismas dificultades
porque apartarse de la ultraortodoxia
significa romper con su vida anterior
una experiencia que aquí bangert en
conoce bien el rabino creció en un
suburbio de nueva york en las sectas
atmar en 2014 dejó a su esposa ya sus
tres hijos para empezar una nueva vida
en alemania con unos pocos dólares en su
bolsillo vacío de mala familia
estas son fotos de mi familia mis dos
hermanos mi hermana mis hijos y la
familia entera
en alemania aquí va avant garde en
retomó los estudios teológicos antes de
ser nombrado rabino de una comunidad
liberal en dresde para el ayudar a estos
jóvenes que abandonan su comunidad
ultra-ortodoxa significa darles apoyo
práctico y teológico
si están buscando su propia identidad
qué significa ser judío se puede ser
judío de otra manera cuando crecemos se
nos enseña que sólo hay una forma de ser
judío se nos enseñó que todas las demás
religiones y todas las demás formas de
judaísmo que eran completamente falsas
esto para ellos es esencial entender
como los demás pueden vivir su religión
en fast fast magdaleno felt
m
pero para el sábado aquí va a ganar ten
sigue usando el extra email el sombrero
de piel que usan los judíos
ultraortodoxos
que hoy
como para mostrarles a los nuevos
miembros que es posible encontrar su
lugar en el mundo liberal sin negar
completamente su pasado jasídico
[Música]